так друзі В мене є окрема думка щодо
цього бюджету і звучить вона дуже просто
це бюджет Перемоги на виборах а не
Перемоги у війні оце Головне те що ми
можемо побачити чому я це можу
констатувати чому я про це можу говорити
Ну будь ласка я прямо ви знаєте з
цифрами для того щоби всім все було
Зрозуміло Я дивлюсь що зараз наші слуги
народу не дуже слухають Може хоча б поди
будь ласка
мінекономіки додається в сім разів в сім
разів мінекономіки будь ласка умножить
на см Подивіться будь ласка Ми
збільшуємо бюджет мінекономіки ідемте
далі
Мінсоцполітики Плю 23 млрд п 23 млрд
мінсоц будь ласка ідемте далі мінкульт
ще п 2 млрд ну зрозуміло треба ще ж
зняти серіали щось має робити 95-й
квартал все зрозуміло плюс 2 млрд
мінкульту А як же ж є Якщо ви думаєте що
збільшення коштів на мінекономіки це
піде підприємцям Та ні друзі по-перше
спитайте сьогодні будь-якого підприємця
що йому найважливіше щоб йому ракети на
голову не падали щоб не вбивали його
виробникі працівників його самого чи щоб
йому якісь були кредити бо ми знаємо
Кому будуть кредити кредити будуть своїм
своїм знов на вілюри і шмілюри будуть
кредити але ніяк на підприємцям далі це
бюджет каральних органів будь ласка бюро
економічної безпеки умножить в 3 по рази
в 3 пови рази бюджет далі дбр +
55%. Ого нормально Добре виконують всі
розпорядження з офісу президента
податкова Плю 40% митниця плюс все
плюс-плюс друзі А якщо в усіх плюс То в
кого ж мінус просте питання в кого мінус
і друзі
Міноборони
міну68 млрд ще раз
міну68 млрд грн на Міністерство оборони
України От дивіться будь ласка оце
бюджет виборів дати щось на соціалку
щось вкрасти через якоби підтримку
підприємництва затиснути всіх через
каральні органи і забрати гроші самого
головного з нашої Перемоги Тому що
тільки Міноборони може добитись Перемоги
ні беп ні митниця нам перемогу не дадуть
Зупиніться все на армію має йти І на
перемогу справжню